don't you dare oh I love drag I follow a
lot of drag queens on Instagram and I'm
really excited what the look so I want
to see how it looks on me I'm not not
very familiar I saw the movie to Wong
foo when I was 12 every time I'm in drag
it's just so empowering and fun you get
to take on this different persona I'm
really excited to get back in touch with
that side of myself I think I'm gonna be
the prettiest I'm gonna go in it I'm
ready to meet my queen they are [ __ ]
it up I know this [ __ ] that chest hair
I am the bargain bin Beauty Ross Dress
for Less you get what you pay for this
is my first time hi I'm pickle the
youngest mills in town doing drag is
really about accentuating the qualities
about myself that are delightful I love
putting that on other people I think
it's really empowering hi my name is
Anita procedure and I am accepting
donations for my procedures so you can
find me on venmo my mama my sister we're
like my biggest influences as a kid so
if they bought her a Cinderella dress
they knew they had to buy me one how
comfortable am I doing people's makeup
not very that means I have to wash my
brushes in the off chance that he
catches you know rickets or diphtheria
not my problem hopefully he ends up
liking what I do but if not oh well it's
going on the internet forever drag to me
is really important
hi my name is Anita procedure I'm Jarrod
yeah I think we're gonna win oh yeah
we're gonna be the prettiest for sure
hi I get to do your makeup yeah do you
know bud Greg a little bit hi pickle
nice to meet you I'll definitely
remember that I'm gonna make you look
like a beautiful cucumber he'll never be
me what look are we thinking I like the
weirder stuff ooh
we're a little crazier do I trust her
yeah of course I trust her she's my
guiding Queen check your wallet
come on BuzzFeed let's get into drag
[Music]
all right ladies let's turn these peas
into cheese let's do it come on
[Music]
can you help me with his lodge well I
sort of [ __ ] up the lip so just trying
to fix that and then I got to put her
wig on and she's gonna be show ready 30
29 28 I wish I could go back in time and
tell me earlier pickled I heard I'll
[ __ ] up
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it up ladies I would like to
present you all she got a procedure oh
my god what do you think I [ __ ] love
it oh my god you look like you're ready
to go to an 80s glamour shot shoot okay
you're ready to see what I did
let's see what happens ladies and
gentlemen penny pincher so basically she
was on her way to high school and the
Zodiac killer snatched her up I like it
I mean I look like I'm in a Swedish
metal band suits my personality all
right welcome to the stage t you come
back oh my goodness look at her wow this
is great I feel I feel like a 1 I know I
like falling in love with it you
recognize yourself and you don't like
you I don't know it's so weird like it's
like I'm controlling oh yeah you're
beautiful tell yourself I'm beautiful
good thanks pickle so I can welcome
[Music]
I think we did great we did what do you
boys think I mean you ladies there Ken
could like literally live as a woman
what about mine she's sort of like Hot
Topic realness I feel like everyone is
beautiful but where the winner is
clearly we came here as boys and we're
leaving as queens let's go girls
where we go let's get the clip actually
guys have to work all right yeah
[Music]